Yeah. I'll tell you what I do miss that.
I didn't think I would dairy milk chocolate. Yeah.
I liked dairy milk because I thought whenever I came to Japan on holiday and
stuff, I was like, I was like, man, the chocolate here's bomb.
I loved the taste. And then after living here a year,
I just feel like I've really used some, some something, something.
Dairy milk they've taken the American way of making a chocolate does say it's
like American,
because what they've done is instead of having more milk and making it like a
richer taste, they're like, Hm, let's just substitute with more sugar. Yeah.
And then you get this kind of weird chemically taste,
which I like Hershey's does Hoshi tastes like,
just in my mind, like question marks with sugar. It's like,
I don't know what this tastes like. It doesn't taste like chocolate.
It tastes like a made,
I am not a fan of Hershey's chocolate does not taste like chocolate.
I used to you're like really? Like Hershey's I still kind of do whenever,
whenever I'm like in the UK, whenever.
It's not as rich. So you can eat more of it. Yeah.
Because what Hershey's tastes like, it tastes like cooking chocolate. Right.
And I don't know why I like the melting pot. I don't know why as a kid,
I loved cooking chocolate because I, it just,
it just like normally for poor quality quality, but as a kid,
I just like, anytime we'd like cook chocolate,
I just like always have to dip my finger in it. And
that's what Hershey's tastes like. So as an adult eating Hershey's tea,
like brings me back to being a kid. And then I have two bars and I'm just like,
okay, this is actually the [inaudible] gone.
It's just chocolate. Now.
American's fan you have a rough ban. I know we clowned you guys all the time,
but light your chocolate is awful.
Please like import some like milk or dairy mackerel thing. Yeah.
The Cadbury milk chocolate or the best Cadbury's dairy. Cadres is dairy milk.
White American company now. But it used to be, I mean,
a lot of the British chocolate's really good.
I think that's one of the things we actually did pretty well.
I think chocolate in the UK is pretty good. Yeah.
I think chocolate. I lived all over Europe. Yeah. That's pretty good.
Get it from Europe honestly.
Well, a bougie and then like the rest of Europe and like.
Swiss chocolates and stuff switched. I just switched shots. great.
It's great. But it's like, it's like seven bucks sometimes.
It's great. And I can, but every time I have a bite of Swiss chocolate,
I can feel the chocolate entering my veins. Depends.
Cause I like, I think my favorite like big brand Swiss chocolate.
It's like lint. I do like, you got to like.
Sit down after you have a bike.
It's great. You like doing a pint of cocaine. It's funny as you go on a journey.
When, when, when you take that one by man, you just like, it needs to be like,
okay. When, when like the truffle inside,
it's just like the perfect consistency.
When you bite off the hard shell and it just the soft truffle and he's just
like, ah, beautiful. My mouth is watering. Just describing it. I love a good
[inaudible] Herrera. She has shame milkshakes. I like the best thing ever.
Cheese ice, ice cream is fun. You can like.
As well. You can like grind it into like a milkshake. It's amazing DIY.
Oh wow. Some places do.
Really. Oh, that sounds fun. I feel like I increase the clause.
Whenever I say forever Russia, I do most cautious word. I've like,
I can think of off the top of my head. I just sounded so good.
I feel the molecule. I do need a top hat every time,
because I feel like you don't.
Berry and Swiss chocolate. You don't eat Swiss chocolate. You know what I mean?
You eat British chocolate.
You can just eat. You know what I mean? The Swiss don't do drugs.
They do chocolate. Oh man.
Sometimes I like buy like a pack of Lin and I'm just like, I'm having it on my,
having a good day.
All of the like Lynn package in one go. Cause I can't like,
cause I feel like I need a pallet cleanser.
Every time I have like a rich chocolate. I'm like give me the,
the wine to go with it. To empty the flavor.
I have. I have a, like a problem where I have one it's enough.
You have a sweet tooth though. Don't you? I do not have a sweet tooth. I don't.
I actually, you always say I'm the only in Japan actually only in Japan.
Cause here's, here's the thing I hardly ever use the snack.
I either I either was that guy in England who would eat a tub of ice cream or
not, I'll go without sweets for like two weeks. I like, I,
there was no in between for me, like only in Japan.
Have I ever like kind of embraced snacking culture and that's just because there
are so many different kinds of sweets and snacks there,
like kind of want to try something. I used to be a sweets guy back in Australia,
but then when I moved here,
I realized that Japan's snack all I confectionary section.
There's a lot more savory. It just tastes way better than the sweet. Yeah.
So I'm just, I always just go for the savory. Now.
It's easy to make something that's tastes good. That's sweet though.
You just put a.
Ton of, because I also feel gross after eating,
because if you ever come to my house in England, if you ask for like anything,
that's not savory snack,
I'm probably not going to have it because if I do have a lint, like, uh,
like a chocolate or like a lint box, that's gone in like a few hours at a time.
That's cause I rarely buy. But when I'm doing I'm like, I'm like super craving.
Yeah. I dunno. I mean,
I haven't had a furrow Shan like probably like a year and a half.
Maybe it doesn't show them in Japan. Oh yeah. Yeah.
You never see them because if you go to like a like international show.
Yeah. Oh, because like in, in the UK that was like the not expensive.
It's like the, the, if you want to look expensive,
but not actually spend too much money for, with it.
I'll see it. Like I never know. Russia just looks fancy.
It sounds fancy.
Fancy is like the price tag. I mean they're expensive.
But compared to like Lin till the North. Yeah.
No. I've had some super, super you're talking about Linton,
fair Rache being like I've really like deep tastes.
I've had shows on that intense.
I've had some like the super expensive chocolates are the ones I feel like you
have to do. You're going,
are you going on a battle with taking a bite out of like the premium economy?
It's like have a little bit better than old.
Have you ever had like truly like you go into like a specialist,
chocolate shop kind of shop. It's fun with chocolates. Always give.
You like the superintendents, like dark chocolate because that's like, yeah.
And then I eat this and I'm like, yeah, it tastes like Ash.
Do my deal. I talk shop. I do.
But there's a limit like, right.
Like it's like 90% cacau. It's just like.
Chocolate tier places. And they'll be like, it's amazing. Isn't it?
It's like 80% like a cooker. And then.
You're like, yeah, that's great. That's good.
Sometimes I have like one bite and then I'm like, Oh,
I got to battle this battle with my mouth. Like trying to get this done, man.
Like I get it.
I was having like an espresso or something to go with it.
Like they'll wash each other out and you know, I'll feel happy.
But when you have one bite of super dark chocolate,
it's stays with you for the rest of the day. You can't,
you cannot get the taste out of your mouth. Yeah.
And I don't want to feel like I've just.
I've never thought about having chocolates with like anything else actually.
With coffee, it's like the best. Yeah. You got to have it with the coffee.
I don't eat chocolate for that.
I don't know. I find it. Cause for me like coffee and tea,
I just liked by itself. I've never tried.
Cause if you dip something into the tea that root, that kind of like changes.
I eat it when you drink it.
Like a pallet cleanser. Because like if your mouth two chocolates.
Keep eating more. My mom, I want to give that a go then,
because I've never thought to combine the two because I never, yeah.
I never thought about chocolate
speakable chocolate was always been a snack for me at a restaurant.
It's like a fancy restaurant. There'll be like coffee and dessert. Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Coffee chocolates. Yeah, because they go together.
It's just like, wow. I didn't think you were supposed to eat all the chocolate.
And then your, you telling me chocolates meant to be just a snack.
I'm not just a dessert. Cause that's,
I guess that's the way I see your chocolates. It's not like I said, I don't,
I never used to snack. It's like it was my dessert, I guess it wasn't.
It was like a full-on I'm either committed.
It's very sad to have a chocolate bar and be like, ah, yes, this is my dessert.